GOP lawmakers are trying to cobble
together an immigration plan before the
next deadline hits as John just
mentioned correspondent Peter Doocy is
at that GOP retreat in West Virginia
tonight good evening Peter
good evening Bret there's reason to
think that Republicans talking about
immigration at this retreat has started
to delete some provisions that are
critical to other Republicans because
there is now talk about an immigration
deal that does not address the visa
lottery program or chain migration but
the president told senators here in West
Virginia today he wants more a
one-for-one bill that just addresses
daca and the border is not enough chain
migration and the Visa Lottery are both
pillars that he is asking Congress to
write into any immigration bill we want
people coming in to our country based on
merit and based on the fact that they
are going to love our country and they
respect our people in our country we
don't want Visa Lottery pick a lottery
ticket
pick a lottery we don't want that so we
want it based on merit many House
Republicans are with the President on
this issue because he likes what people
in their districts like and the lawmaker
tasked with defending the house is
forecasting how immigration is going to
play in the midterms the other side
frankly would love to have nothing
happen and campaign against that and
frankly I don't want a bad deal I don't
think we should take a bad deal but we
need to hold them accountable for what
they do and don't do if they don't want
to come together and get a deal then
there may not be a deal that's had
control of the Congress isn't the only
thing hanging in the balance because
Congress actually shut down the last
time there was a daca fight but the
majority leader Mitch McConnell said
today he doesn't think that's going to
be an issue again he thinks Democrats
learned their lesson
garment shop my favorite old Kentucky
country sayings is no education in the
second kick of a mule and so I think it
will be a new level of seriousness here
that means McConnell thinks that
Democrats are gonna look the other way
and vote to keep the government open
next week even if there is no daca deal
in place even though that's what a lot
of them thought he was promising when
they agreed to vote to keep the to end
the shutdown last time right
no education in the second kick of a
mule the Senate Majority Leader sounds
in like senator Kennedy from Louisiana
Peter thank you